enough cannot be said of my relationship
with Gary Marshall and what that's done
for me as a person just having the
confidence to be funny and goofy she was
nineteen and came to my office and
wouldn't sit down
she was so macho Hasenpfeffer
incorporated no no no to see these kids
when they're young and suddenly they
come up and they're household words it
really was my joy since television with
Henry Winkler Scott Baio you make stars
well I'll make them I help people know
they are stars Julia and Goldie Kate all
the stars we love most well they adored
Gary not just for his work behind the
scenes but for his big heart it's all
about family for Gary and his
relationships with everybody you know
when I was on overboard as a kid you
know he likes to let the kids yell out
you know action or rolling and I
remember being that little kid on his
set and I watched Ryder and he's sitting
with Gary and he's yelling out and Gary
just my life more than 64 movies and TV
shows many of our all-time favorites but
did you know Gary was the one behind the
camera directing Bette Midler in beaches
but Gary we knew was funny humble always
open to people's ideas we were on 14
sets with him did nearly 30 sit downs
over more than three decades every star
in the industry wanted the chance to
work with a Hollywood legend I don't
care if I was walking into sweethearts
you like the yellow ones of the green
all right cool Thank You Garrett I'm out
he's got this really kind genuine
sweetness trick that's funny oh I love
you so much I'm so glad to hear okay
that's a little tougher tougher here oh
heck how are you did you bow your back
Hector Elizondo within 18 of Gary's
films we spoke with him last night just
after we got the news that Gary had
passed away due to complications from
pneumonia he meant toward so many people
when he found somebody with it the
character he said we've got to take care
of her make the situation better than
you find it man it's not about you it
was a special man and a special friend
out of everything that you've done what
do you most want to be remembered for
then I made people laugh and made the
day a little better I don't I always
said I don't know how to change the
world but I can change the day for you I
make you laugh and happy one day